لا منصه من تجديد الحصار على بعض الاحياء
الصينيه مثل ما حدث هنا في شونجاي تقول
السلطات الصينيه لا سيما بعد الاحتجاجات
الضخم نهايه الاسبوع الماضي استياء من
السياسات الصارمه لمكافحه فيروس كورونا
بعد ثلاث سنوات من بدء الجائحه
لا اتاثر كثيرا باجراءات الحجر لكن ان ارى
هؤلاء الناس يدافعون عن الحريه فهو امر
ملهم للغايه
[موسيقى]
يجب تحديد المصابين ووضعهم في الحجر الصحي
لا يجب عزل المبنى باكمله او الحي باكمله
لكن على الرغم من القمع استمرت الاحتجاجات
ما دفع بالسلطات الصينيه التي لا تريد ان
تغير من سياستها بشكل جذري الى التواصل مع
السكان والتاكيد على مساله الوقايه
نحن بحاجه الى تسريع التطعيم ضد كوفي 19
خاصه للمسنين نامل ان يتمكن كبار السن من
اكمال التطعيم بشكل فعال في اقرب وقت ممكن
لحمايه صحتهم
واسع نطاق على سكانها فقد 65% من الاشخاص
الذين تزيد اعمارهم عن 80 عاما يتمتعون
بالحمايه وبالتالي فان الرفع الجذري
للقيود الصحيه يمكن ان يتسبب في موجه من
الوباء والعديد من الوفيات ويلحق الضرر
بصوره الصين المتحكمه في الوباء صوره اردت
بكين ان تسوقها للعالم منذ بدايه الاسماء